assalamualaikum greetings a peace how
you guys doing guess who I found
say Salaam is how you doing what's
happening everybody out there how they
I'm chillin what Eddie the man the damn
show keepin it real real Sally show
there's some I'm gonna share with you
but hopefully there's gonna be a lot of
good that's gonna come from from this
you know you've heard of Chuck I worry
Chuck Lorre
[Music]
[Applause]
we was at the wheel of fortune
Oh Chuck Woolery is it the love
connection love connection in the wheel
of fortune hey if people don't know
their history they don't know that Chuck
Woolery is that love connection guy he
likes to spread love yeah now here's
something you know Islamophobia is a 300
plus million dollar industry I mean
that's how much is spent annually you
know where people are throwing dirt I
see you you act you you you're Muslim
yep
and obviously were using those I don't
know Muslim is simply one who submits to
the will of that Jesus was a Muslim
Abraham was a myself all the messages of
God were those was submitted to look
back it's a peaceful way of life calling
you to have a direct connection with the
greater the heavens and earth now check
it out
Islam is what we follow now Chuck
Woolery I remember he I was I watched
that game they spin the yeah but Chuck
said something and what just say here's
what Chuck said we want to send a
message to Chuck
we'll get it from you Tara so Chuck said
recently he said look if you don't know
Islam is evil then you don't know
history and you refuse to reason I'm not
saying that every Muslim is evil
different Chuck would you say the job
hours how old Chuck has lost his love
connection to what Chuck what history oh
my god I would be like hey the history
of Chuck is connecting love so where's
your love Chuck let's get it back
you see I usually tell people that you
know
obviously people they see a lot of
things blowing up yeah they see you know
human beings who are fallible you know
often I make this analogy that you know
if a human being
crashes the car you don't break you
don't blame the manufacturer for the
drunk driver I know that's true so
there's a lot of you know there's a lot
of things going on out there but okay
what about me as a black guy the vast
majority of people who are doing the
mass shootings in America not Muslims at
all
so exactly the young white men can I say
that the you know Christianity was evil
because of the KKK and what they did to
my people could I say that job
what can I blame up the whole religion
of Christianity everybody that followed
Christ you know for this they they
killed him in the name of the Lord in
the name of Jesus they burned crosses
and they did Chuck do you know your
history come on baby we need you build
that love and next Chuck movie the way
you read baby that's our message to you
chuck is that one of love understanding
continue to watch our shows if you
haven't draw the Chuck will be friends
and you'll learn about Islam call us
also 1 862 Islam if you have any
misconceptions and you want those those
tough questions answered call us and
Chuck come on the show we can have a
nice dialogue yeah say social setting so
Chuck beta make you tweet that stuff
outdated it's not true you know it's not
true Chuck we need you we miss you
[Applause]